So in order to learn about programming, we need to learn
new language. This will be a way to describe what we want
the computer to do in a much more precise way than we
could in a natural language like English. And it's a way to
describe programs that the Python interpreter can run. One of the
best ways to learn a programming language is to just try things.
You can try that in the Python interpreter that's running in your
browser. Let's, for example, try running print 2 plus 2 plus. In
English, someone could probably guess that the value of 2 plus
2 plus should be 4. In Python, when we try running
this, we get an error. And the reason we get an
error is that this is not actually part of the Python
language. The Python interpreter only knows how to evaluate code that's
part of the Python language. If you try to evaluate something
that's not part of the Python language, it will give you
an error. Errors look a bit scary, the way they print out.
But there's nothing bad that can happen. It's perfectly okay to
try running code. If it produces an error, that's one of
the ways to learn about programming. The error we got here
is what's called a syntax error. That means that what we
tried to evaluate is not actually part of the Python language.
Like English, Python has a grammar that defines what strings are
in the language. In English, we can make lots of sentences
that are not completely grammatical, and
people still understand them, but there's
some underlying grammar behind the language. Those of you who are
native English speakers, might have learned rules like this in what was
once called grammar school. Those of you who learned English as a
second language, probably learned rules like
this when you were learning English.
So, English has a rule that says you can make a
sentence. By combining a subject with a verb, followed by an object.
Almost every language has a rule sort of like this. The order
of the subject and the verb and the object might be different,
but there's a way to combine those three things to
form a sentence. The subject could be a noun. The object
could also be a noun. And then each of these
parts of speech, well, we have lots of things they could
be. So a verb could be the word eat. A
verb could also be the word like, and there are lots
of other words that the verb could be. A noun could
be the word I, a noun could be the word Python,
a noun could be the word cookies. The actual English
grammar is of course, much larger and more complex than this.
But we can still think of it as having rules like
this that allow us to form sentences from the parts of
speech that we know, from the words that make those
parts of speech. The way we're writing grammars here is a
notation called Backus-Naur Form. And this was invented by John Backus.
So John Backus was the lead designer of the Fortran programming
language back in the 1950s at IBM. This was one
of the first widely used programming languages. And the way
they described the Fortran language was with lots of examples
and text explaining what they meant. And this is a shot
from the actual manual for the first version of Fortran.
This works okay, many programmers were able to understand it and
guess correctly what it meant, but was not nearly precise
enough. And when it came time to design a later language,
which was the language called ALGOL, it became
clear that this informal way of describing languages
wasn't precise enough. And John Backus invented the
notation that we're using here to describe languages.